[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
another way all right
welcome back to the break room everybody
our daily nerdy news show that keeps you
updated on everything you need to know
and today what we all need to know is
about that across this spider verse oh
my goodness it just dropped today
um we're gonna be talking about that I
think for the entirety of this episode
why not there's so much to talk about
it's a beefy boy we've already got a
reaction up on the channel uh breakdowns
to come breakdowns plural yeah multiple
breakdowns of that trailer will be
coming out over the next couple days on
our Channel
um you know we might get into some of
this insane HBO Max news the uh the evil
super villain David zazlov is enacting
his Revenge come on let's show you
coward you're just down this come on the
show or are you
we're in Winnipeg uh but with me to
mostly discuss the spider verse
um from uh Earth uh 6969 Brandon Barrick
oh nice
from from Earth she she
hey guys and don't forget you can catch
me at the Falcon theater with my all red
nose dance group Insane Clown Posse
starting tomorrow uh and ending tomorrow
[Laughter]
and from Earth uh
um but we want to talk about this we got
uh we got that spider first trailer
dropped today they've been kind of uh
teasing it for a while and then
accompanying that trailer we got Sony
put out like an official uh kind of
interview segment with uh Lord and
Miller the producers of this film and
the original uh into the spider-verse
film and uh Spider Gwen voice actor
herself
um uh hailee Stein Haley Steinfeld sorry
I drew a blanket only for a moment uh
empty took the name right out of your
mouth respect to you Miss Steinfeld
you're doing great work in everything
but
um they put this interview out behind a
paywall what on YouTube premium in this
economy in this economy but you know
what we paid for it uh both because we
support uh YouTube creators even when
they're giant multinational companies
and uh we wanted to bring you the
details about it and again uh full
breakdowns of that trailer will be
coming from uh Eric Mt and Jessica over
the next couple days they're gonna be
breaking down parts of it uh in
different totally different ways they
already did their reaction video
um but we want to talk about that after
party video the interview they they
answered some fan questions they kind of
talked about different elements that are
going to be in the film that were shown
in the trailer
um and we want to get we have some big
questions that we want to try to
speculate on if you have some thoughts
some theories some questions you're
wondering about from that trailer uh
throw those in the chat we'll try to
answer some of those obviously we'll be
responding to all super chats we
appreciate anybody
responding to the most recent Super Chat
in fact could we get that person blocked
okay
there's enough there's enough hate in
the world why are we gonna come for uh
Tommy's uh beloved Buffalo Bills listen
uh Saturday's forecast in Buffalo calls
for seven inches of snow and four and a
half inches of back toe so don't worry
I'll be home baby Dr nasty said in that
yeah that's super cheap well we're a bit
of strange because I'm suing him for uh
pal practice
yes that's when you PayPal your doctor
and he accidentally Cuts you open and
doesn't show you that job accident but
we will We Will and thank you Jordan aka
Dr nasty for the Super Chat we
appreciate everybody it throws us a
couple of doubloons in the chat helps us
bring uh the show to you but first
things first
um uh they mentioned Lord Miller again
producers of this film producers also
have the original spider-verse movie as
well as the Lego uh
um movie
um Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs uh
the 21 Jump Street franchises uh those
those guys have done a lot of fun work
uh famously fired off of solo yes
um fired like a plasma torpedo out of
one of those uh destroyers
but they mentioned and we can kind of
tell in the trailer right Peter B Parker
and his MJ are still together and they
have a daughter uh a half spider
daughter named Mayday
argument but she's got some spider blood
in her and there's a little bit of a
theme established there she is very cute
uh she was not shown in the actual
trailer but was mentioned in this after
party because you can tell if you look
in the trailer that uh Peter B Parker is
wearing a Baby Bjorn yeah so baby's not
currently with him when we see him but
he's doing some dading out there and
there's a little bit of a theme there
because we also see Jessica Drew Spider
Woman fully pregos she's pregnant in the
images we see there we go
um kind of make out a little baby bump
there and that's of course a famous
Comics run
um during Secret Wars she was like
pregnant during Secret Wars and also
like the child May Day there's precedent
for that there's been lots of like
spider children over the years and
different alternate universes but there
was like a what-if comic where Peter and
MJ had a kid and its name was May Day
they've had lots of kids that are often
named either after Ben Parker or Aunt
May or there was another one like anime
Man anime yeah uh adorable yeah one time
one of their kids grows up to be the
Hobgoblin oh and fascinating stuff like
tons of kids out there uh but this one's
very interesting and they mentioned that
like she does because she has like a
little bit of that spider blood she's
got some Powers she's like crawling on
the wall so it's I bet Peter B Parker is
like looking for her like she's escaping
there's gonna be some fun like
Adventures in Babysitting yeah style
things where like he's chasing her out
onto the ledge of a of a skyscraper
because she can walk on walls and stuff
like that right yeah and I guess a kind
of a darker more glossed over very
briefly uh Spider-Man's wife ham Jay
gave uh birth to a litter of piglets but
they were sold to Bob Evans uh Bob Evans
Restaurant so unfortunately we see
spider ham in the morning Peter Parker
I mean we didn't see Spiderman Spiderman
no spider Noir yeah
uh Spider-Man 2099 Miguel like we saw
him at the post-credits scene we also
saw in those in those those big runs I
know we're going to talk more about all
this better all I think three different
variations of video games Spider-Man
were in there there was the there was
the Spider-Man from the uh the
PlayStation 4. from Miles Morales from
Miles Morales and then there was also I
think the PlayStation one Spider-Man
made it appearance my friend uh Joe sent
me a uh a photo with a circle that I was
trying to confirm before I reported it I
have not yet and again we'll get uh in
our full breakdowns that will be coming
out on the channel they will you better
believe they will be finding every
possible uh Spider or they won't sleep
and they won't go home to their families
at Christmas that's right but speaking
of families right like the Lord Miller
kind of re-emphasized you know family is
a big part of this franchise obviously
the first spider-verse movie is all
about about miles and his parents his
uncle right and like dealing with that
and like they kind of Lord Miller went
out of their way to say like what part
of what makes miles special is like he
comes from intact family neither of his
parents are dead unlike most other
spider characters right uh and so that's
an important part of kind of his story
yeah um and so like you'd see like oh
new spider families are being you know
created here too and like with that kind
of intergenerational uh relationship my
my that'll be interesting too if it
plays into this movie a little more the
idea of it he sees that every other
Spider-Man that has lost their parents
and if he's just like constantly
concerned about his own parents yeah
they did say in the after party about
how uh it was one of the director's idea
to develop the trailer the way they did
and it was interesting that they chose
to have that very long scene at the
beginning with uh miles and his mother
and like she's worried about him and you
know he's clearly wants to move on and
go out there and be a part of this his
mom's not his dad right he's dead who's
a much bigger part of the first film we
actually didn't get a lot of his mom in
that first movie right yeah yeah so I
think that is a great parallel for yeah
like what Peter B Parker is going to be
doing with his kid because you know in
the first movie you know him and MJ were
strange I think they were like divorced
now they've gotten back together and
have a kid so it's like now he's got to
worry about that stuff all over again
and what drove them apart in the first
place was like his constant worry and
concern but now he's got double that
right yeah so it'll be a good theme for
the movie yeah it adds nice stakes when
you're worried about your family members
and your loved ones right and their
safety and everybody kind of has a
little bit of that delicious steaks
delicious steaks uh so Lord Miller
referred to that kind of uh that
interdimensional place where we see all
of those different spider characters
hanging out uh as Miguel O'Hara's spider
Force right and I guess that might not
necessarily be the place maybe that is
the group of people that are
congregating there all the different
spider people are the spider Force
um and it looks like it might be based
in Earth 2099 as we get uh we got kind
of another look at that universe's Nueva
York uh which is where Miguel O'Hara
Spider-Man 29.9 comes from
um but yeah they're kind of hanging out
in this weird kind of like abstract
almost looking Place yeah sure I could
all stick to the wall running and
everything we can say however they want
maybe they just have those new Sketchers
Skechers if you want shoes that can walk
up and down walls don't get Sketchers
because you'll be paralyzed oh
technically all don't get all shoes uh
but well real quick they they mentioned
that that place uh in Nueva York in
general right look at the art style is
based on Sid Mead uh who's a really
popular and prolific artists do a lot of
work in the 70s and 80s that's what La
looks like today we did it we got it we
did it famously he contributed a lot of
design work to the original Blade Runner
so he also worked on Blade Runner 2049
uh Tron he contributed to uh it was his
famous kind of uh futurist artist worked
in the alien movies like that guy
interested any kind of cool futuristic
franchise uh Sid Mead had something to
do with but he had those famous kind of
that art style is is what they're
mimicking there I was just gonna say
Tomorrowland that was the the big
influences I know that movie didn't
necessarily knock anyone's socks off I
personally enjoyed it and that draw that
second drawing that we saw had uh that
were there's a lot of like Sid Mead's
influence on like Epcot right yes it
feels like that
streamline so they did mention him this
after party thing it also you can kind
of see the unfinished lines like you can
see the old infrastructure still there
and how this was on top of it yeah which
I which I do really like it's also
fascinating like all these spider boys
and girls are hanging out together but
in the first movie it was very much like
if you're not supposed to be in this
Dimension it's painful to be here or
you're constantly like twitching and
stuff but all of them they figured out I
mean we saw on the end of the first
movie that Miguel figures out the little
wrist thing so I assume that everyone on
the spider force is given one of these
and I guess they have the time to leave
their own universe and come and hang out
I know are there are there a thousand uh
Green Goblins and Dr Octopus is just
running amok and all those you know I
think there's a thousand Graves
they've killed all their enemies in
their home world oh and it's a Utopia
they got nothing to do but go hang out
at the Spider Boys spider Force they all
get fun watches yeah cute you haven't
stood up in a while that's what mine
says
um they mentioned So speaking of that
spider Force Lord Miller mentioned uh
that Gwen was invited to join that group
and Miles was not and that Gwen can't
tell him why yeah yeah they also they
described it as like you know they
threads related to like if you uh if
you're like in a relationship and
someone's older and they go away to
college and you want to go hang out and
they're like uh don't don't come here I
got new College friends yeah she might
be like hey I got new spider Force
friends I don't quite have time for
another teenage boy yeah though at the
end of the first movie she comes back to
him and is like hey come come hang out
hey come hang out with us uh but maybe
now after a while she's like yeah well I
got bigger things this is one of the
maybe two big questions I had coming out
of this trailer right and and they're
kind of aligned why was Miles not
invited every other spider character we
think was and why is miguelo Spider-Man
2099 beating up like attacking him right
why would it's the only seems like
everybody is chasing him in one shot
right it seems like all the spider
characters are going after miles why do
we think that is I wonder if he is the
key to releasing these I mean both we
know the spot is going to be the bad guy
but there might be other
interdimensional bad guys and maybe for
whatever reason miles is the one who
they can't they can't they can't kind of
put like a restrainer bolt on like it's
like all right they've got to stop him
like he can't be he can't maybe he can't
have one of the wristbands maybe there's
something that like there's something
with his this is electricity yeah maybe
there's also the fact that he comes from
a universe where there was a Spider-Man
and that Spider-Man died right that's
true I think he's almost like the second
place or something that makes him
different right
um yeah that's interesting Mary Smith uh
in the chat had a question how do you
think Gwen and Miles relationship will
evolve in this movie well I have Mary
just to give you a a hot take hot
prediction because we know this is the
second of a third movie I think it's
gonna devolve yeah I think they're going
to end up not for the weather or not not
not uh simpatico by the end of this
movie only to joyously reunite uh by the
by the third movie yeah and just as
deserve for everybody right this is uh
they they're kind of working on two
sequels at the same time this movie's
coming out in June of 2023 and then
following that in 2024 we're getting
the third movie and it is across the
spiders too yeah beyond the spider verse
I was waiting for whatever you know
they're they're very cleverly naming
these by just changing one preposition
yes
um but uh so it can be hard we'll just
say spider verse three into across um so
this is this is The Empire Strikes Back
of the trailer yeah and so it'll
probably be dark right I mean we might
lose some uh battles here uh the Vic the
we can only assume in an Infinity War
kind of way the villain might kind of
win yeah and then we need that third
movie a bit of a cliffhanger into that
movie where where Miles and the Gang get
to get to win in the end
um but yeah oh and Tommy I think just
mentioned the spot who we've been told
is the villain of this film not shown at
all in this trailer I was waiting to see
but no no this box I suspect again with
my Nostradamus abilities uh that we will
have an individual spot feature at I
think you know with animation sometimes
they do very nice like character
featurettes I think we'll get plenty uh
of introduction to the spot uh via maybe
a short animated feature at yeah and
sorry I we kind of moved on without
really directly answering Mary Smith
yeah sorry Mary oh Gwen and Miles
relationship will evolve no it was my
fault Tommy there's no need for you to
apologize okay I take it back someone
apologize I apologize uh but yeah it
does feel like it will be on the Rocks
maybe there's some Growing Pains here
for sure uh right that first movie was
kind of like their like kind of
courtship and kind of like falling for
each other a little bit maybe this is
kind of like they've grown apart they
have different priorities she's got a
new group of friends and those friends
maybe want to beat up yeah well and they
said in the after party right like
long-distance relationships are tough
especially across universes yes don't
expect this relationship to be on Solid
Ground uh there's a run in the comics
called sitting in a tree that their
relationship will be partially based on
so if you want a little more hint maybe
go check that out
a-i-s-s-i-n-g w e b b i n g uh film
just send in a Super Chat saying should
Peter be concern that here MJ will
probably there's missing a word I bet
it's die during May days oh I don't
think so I think it's uh convert to
Scientology I mean I think Peter will be
very concerned yes that he could die or
be killed interesting with him being the
Uncle Ben to his own daughter yeah I
mean that would be the thing that rips
my heart out if they kill Peter B Parker
in this film no don't do after after the
Redemption Arc he gets in the first
movie and like getting back together
with MJ having a kid taking him away
would be dark and that's a great way to
end this move I got it done no I
wouldn't doubt if if this if this is
going to be Empire Strikes Back the dark
just brings him in carbonite who do you
think I don't think they're gonna kill
miles I don't think they'll kill Gwen no
it seems like Peter B might be the top
candidate do they have to kill someone
does someone have to die in every movie
yes yes that's tell that to Queen
ramonda
Peter Parker's whole existence is people
around him dying constantly I mean and
if we don't get some orphans if orphans
aren't made does it even you know maybe
it does look suspiciously like a little
red-headed orphan that we all know named
[Laughter]
um yeah we also got our first look Ed
fighter Gwen's universe she would only
ever been seen in miles's Universe oh
and isn't that beautiful yeah it's uh
based on a watercolor style called Gauss
I don't know it's it's a an opaque
watercolor style so they add something
to watercolor paint is this important is
it water uh nope okay we're all my paint
Fanatics at Super Chat that's how you
pronounce it yeah yeah well I think our
audience might be more paint huffing oh
that's true well they you know people
throw out half used cans of spray paint
every day so our audience probably ends
up drinking it you guys if you're a
huffing watercolors you're not dumpsters
we drink paint around Christmas time
what else do we love you guys
um but uh they mentioned that her world
changes based on her moods what it's
almost like I got a mood ring quality so
she's like the goddess of their of her
world I don't know and maybe that's just
like a um a a perspective oh yeah
because we see the world through her
eyes Okay because yeah it doesn't that
would be wild if yeah I mean there's
also just the fact that these are
animated worlds like do the characters
in these worlds see the flips and the
Hong
that show up around them do they see
that are they aware of those things I
don't know I mean we know in our world
that when God cries we get rain or when
he does his uh shake weight exercises
and sweats we get salty rain
salty rain yeah supposed to the Sweet
rain we sometimes get you guys never
tasted sweet rain before Chocolate Rain
is our good friend
I can't this is supposed to be a serious
conversation and that's important
conversation they mentioned everybody's
universe is drawn differently yeah like
how comic books are drawn by different
artists yeah right and we got speaking
of that we got another look at Earth
50101 AKA
which is like Mumbai and Manhattan and
that's a a India inspired Universe I
love it uh and we got our first look at
Spider-Man India AKA pivotar prabhakar
thank you Tommy
um yeah thank you to my Indian neighbors
growing up I did some great concept art
there of uh pivotar
um yeah and the art style here is based
on the 70s there were some 70s
Spider-Man comic books from India
um and they they mentioned in the
interview Lord Miller that it's like
Manhattan but in Reverse so that
skyscrapers actually go down into the
ground I need a poster of that for my
room which doesn't make sense if you're
in a really hot climate yeah it's kind
of hard to swing around underground
skyscrapers oh that's a good point could
that affect his power set maybe he does
something else it could be a utility
where they did that to like because of
superheroes they were like put the
skyscrapers down so they can't mess with
us there was a fun thing with uh Marvel
Comics where I love that they're
incorporating this into the movie where
they would sell the rights uh you know
back in the 70s and 80s before there was
more worldwide kind of like sharing
Comics they would sell the rights of
these characters to different countries
they would develop their own story lines
especially with Spider-Man the most
popular character in the world uh and I
love that they're bringing that that
into this movie that the idea is no
we're canonizing these versions they're
gonna be real and like these are just
different universes yeah it's a really
cool idea Tolkien actually did that with
his characters he sold Lord of the Rings
to Canada and instead of uh Sarah on me
they had sorry
sorry
totally worth it oh Gandalf
did you get any of that maple syrup I
left at your front door you shall not
how many kilometers is it tomorrow uh
yeah One does not simply walk into
mardor all the all the hobbits have
eleven season Tim Hortons okay
um
okay
you're on your high horse up there where
are you at Christian unpronounceable I
actually didn't win a Canadian viewer
see you soon Niagara Falls and I'm going
over the falls this time Tommy will be
up in that neighborhood very soon that's
right uh and then learn I actually asked
if that's just going to be a cameo by uh
Spider-Man India and they were like no
we're actually going to spend a decent
amount of time uh either Lord or Miller
I don't know which one switch uh even
said it's a whole ass reel which are
real in in movie parlance is about 10 to
12 minutes this is that teaser we got
last year at Brazil Comic Con ccxp they
shot a little bit of it
um of them swinging around in that area
what platform is your ass real on again
are you is that a Vimeo link we can all
look up that's right a whole apps for
you my [ __ ] reel is
some would argue that's the break room
this is supposed to be a serious
conversation about Spider-Man we are I'm
about to get serious Spider-Woman AKA
Jessica Drew played by Issa Rae is
pregnant in this not by me based on a
run during Secret Wars yeah all right
and they mentioned that Gwen uh looks up
to her and it kind of views her as like
a mentor or a role model yeah because
then you know there's not as many female
spider people running around on spider
Force she's looking for a role model I
like it
um we also not seen in the trailer but
they did mention
um or maybe briefly seen in the trailer
what uh see if Jessica found I think
yeah yeah they did they definitely did
an image reveal in the after party yeah
yeah we got our first look at spider
Punk and he looks awesome uh AKA Hobie
Brown uh a character played by Daniel
kaluya
um he's uh Gwen's best friend which
makes miles a bit jealous Gwen actually
wears Hobbies Chuck Taylors throughout
the movie which is a little Easter egg
you can see I love that and they better
sell those shots
yeah they pointed out in that after
party what a weird thing to call it an
aftermarket I know uh and that
conversation the three of them had alone
in a movie theater yeah
um that uh Daniel is actually from
Camden where like the birth of punk yeah
it's like the neighborhood I think the
sex pistol I always forget that he's
British uh because I think he does a
great American accent uh he uh he's from
that area so he's like the perfect
choice to play that character I love it
yeah it's gonna be cool the Brits gave
us so many of their actors doing amazing
English accents or American accents and
then we sent them back our best Renee
Zellweger and Anne Hathaway we said you
guys can have them and they'll do
British
effective both of those actors
and I think I do
a push accent whoa booking BBC
um oh no my Australian X is taking over
this might have been hyperbole but one
either Lord and Miller mentioned is the
biggest animation crew in the credits
they said thousand people in the credits
now a lot of these Marvel movies have a
ton of people in the credits but we were
mentioning there's a reason how many
directors are listed on there's at least
three directors listed and we were
speculating that some of that is because
like direct each director was kind of
like in charge of different characters
storylines or different universes and
they mentioned the I mean they said that
one of the was a was it a board artist
from the first movie is take some
director and then they have another guy
whose name is escaping me who is like
the you know regarded as the best action
director in animation yeah so which is
like so I was thinking about that and
like what an incredible skill to have to
take a you know what we know as action
scenes and Chase scenes and things like
that in live action and translate them
to being drawn I mean I know they go
from like board to camera but those are
just kind of like you know just board
drawings these are now like finely
animated you know motion whatever motion
animation to do action of that it has to
be so difficult you can't make the
argument that 90 of the action in Marvel
movies is animated you know that's a
great point it's made before they shoot
that's a really good price this huge
animation I mean we were talking about
this movie was supposed to be coming out
right now yeah it is our what got pushed
back right so I'm wondering like this
huge animation crew is it part of like
well we're making two together at the
same time because the Beyond is going to
come out like in a year from the release
of this film so it's like that kind of
makes sense a massive huge crew they're
just working more to get these two
movies out there and especially we were
talking about just to zoom out for a
second how great that first spider-verse
movie was it blew everybody away I don't
think a lot of people had high
expectations for it or not they weren't
low expectations we didn't think it was
gonna be bad but we had never watched a
big animated superhero movie in movie
theaters before right and like we didn't
really know what to expect and then it
peeled all of our wigs back and we loved
that movie and so they definitely are
just trying to make sure oh Tommy's
peeling his wig back for us right now
not since Batman The Mask of the
Fantastic yeah has that animated I
watched that on home videos The
Incredibles I think oh the incredible
sure yeah but like you know it wasn't
something we were in The Habit it was a
surprise hit um and so they I think
they're just taking their time because
they want to make sure they live up to
the X-ray camera because now we will not
have low expectations for the film we
are very high
um speaking of which a big part of that
first movie was the great soundtrack
good music there
um songs like sunflower the post Malone
song all that stuff
um and this movie uh the music is gonna
be handled by Metro Boomin um which is
something you do when you take the bus
and you've had too many burritos no ah
that is a dad joke
ladies and gentlemen who is Metro
booming on this bus I swear to God we
will not stop at the casino unless
someone confesses who's been Metro
booming but he's a real
talented
sure
he's a great you know
he's rolling Savage and uh made migos's
bad and boujee which is a great time uh
so he's you know kind of overseeing the
music in this film so we can only assume
I have a great soundtrack yeah
um hell yeah yeah but yeah as we
mentioned before no spider ham in this
trailer no Spider-Man Noir no Penny
Parker I want to see them come back
please come on everybody please Bucky
Barnes ATL in the chat asking why do you
think the other Spider-Man are going
after miles yeah we'll throw some quick
theories I think he's the key to
allowing villains into the uh uh Spider
Force yeah the spider Force area and
also possibly allowing villains to
transport back and forth between other
universities finding Spider-Man and
Spider people that are specifically
vulnerable to those villains abilities
there could also be a situation a weird
like time situation where it's I don't
know if like miles becomes the spot in
some futuristic way and they're trying
to stop him in a Franklin Richards kind
of a way idea that yeah the spot needs
miles unique power set to like really
power up or something like that oh
interesting yeah it was strange they do
not have the spot on this at all like
why they're hiding that fact about this
movie it makes me assume there's gonna
be another trailer before well you know
in the first spider-verse movie they
kind of hit we got Kingpin right there
at the beginning we didn't know who Dr
Octopus was gonna be right like they did
a good job but we didn't know who the
prowler really was right they did a good
job of slowly revealing the villains and
not necessarily in the promotional
materials so and a quick Brandon you
know a little bit about the spot from
comic book lore right it was like a a
scientist character yeah it was like a
classic comic book story I came around
in like 1984 he was a scientist who was
messing around with this technology uh
tested it out and it went awry and now
he's got the spots that are like a
little interdimensional holes on his
body and create these like tunnels uh so
yeah it makes me think this is like a
important like miles is obviously
there's something they don't want him to
know and they're keeping him out of the
spider Force for a reason yes uh and so
yeah him showing up is probably throwing
a wrench and everything producer John
mentioned kind of along that line there
is a shot of miles and some kind of
chamber that looks like it might like
transform you in some way maybe that's
hinting at his potential to become the
spot somehow
um I don't know which you know the
spider verse as far as we know does not
involve time travel no right it does
involve multi Multiverse travel but not
time travel but maybe that could be
introduced in this one to really
complicated I guess it's debatable if
you consider that Spider-Man Noir is at
a different time but his whole universe
is like that so I don't know how time
works in that way Ruth in the chat
asking do you do you guys think silk
will be in this we know uh Amazon is
developing a silk series he's very smart
of Sony to yeah plant the seeds of cell
care yeah and I don't see why you
wouldn't if you've got every Spider-Man
available uh use them I mean when they
talk about Sony owning 900 characters we
saw about a hundred of them in this yeah
you know like the the universal profile
of both Miles Morales and spider Gwen
really raised by this first animated
movie right so it's like it would make
sense if they want some characters to
grow going forward maybe they would put
them in here interesting uh Mr Johnson
2024. do you think Tom Holland will be
in this well they're a good move the
original movie had a planned uh Toby
Andrew Tom Holland Cameo right like they
they did they did the voice track I
think in one of the Subways there was
going to be all the other Spider-Man
talking now I wonder if the events of no
way home had already been kind of
planned yeah I didn't want to spoil them
like that but I I yeah I could see Tom
Holland Cameo I mean this why not it's a
little it's kind of fun well and the
first the the Peter Parker that dies in
Miles Universe right a lot of his story
was mapped onto to Toby's story right
this very similar sequences from from
the Sam Remy
Spiderman movies so they could use Tom
Holland and not necessarily be like the
MCU Tom Holland uh but just like a
variant that's very similar to Tom
Holland Chris Pine voices the voice of
that Spiderman okay uh does a great job
on the soundtrack singing Spidey Bells
it's a holiday classic be sure to play
it this year at all your holiday Parks I
can't stop playing with my Spidey Bells
now
we want to shout out our good friends at
geology yes geology is a 15 time
award-winning personalized skin care
company recognized in hypebeast birdie
Men's Health Esquire and ask men
grooming Awards with over six thousand
five star reviews wow I can't even get
six women to give me a one star review
that's because I don't have enough
geology on my face and they've recently
expanded to offer products for pretty
much whatever you need all you got to do
is take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz and geology figures out your
routine for you I entered the quiz and
they just said no thank you if you need
it that's not true they said we can help
but it's you're more of a band he said
we don't ship buckets that's right uh if
you need Hair Care use geology is
co-wash and specifically formulated
cream cleanser that Zach is holding
right there removes build up and
cleanses the hair without big lather or
harsh ingredients of typical shampoo if
you're if you got a weak stream like I
do at my house you can't have a lot of
land you're talking about the shower
yeah maybe I don't know and for the rest
of your shower routine you can use their
body washes they're free of harsh
ingredients they smell great and the
packaging is refillable how great is
that that's very cool less waste more
taste all right well they'll taste them
after before the after the shower
protect your skin with environmental
stressor uh from environmental stressors
with vitamin C plus e ferulix serum to
keep your skin looking young and healthy
and then a bit of Dermatology tested
aluminum free deodorant that quite
honestly smells great that's what you
want out of a deodorant if it's if your
deodorant smells bad you got to talk to
your guy because you got a wrong
deodorant dealer right now for a limited
time geology is hooking up our audience
with an absolutely insane offer if you
use code new rockstars they will give
you an additional 70 off their
award-winning skin care products a good
deal new rock stars you use the code it
makes us look good guys come on that
discount applies whether you're stocking
up for yourself
there's someone else's stocking instead
either way geology has got you covered
check out their awesome gift sets
featuring all of your favorite geology
products remember that's code new
rockstars to save 70 I gotta say I want
to try out this cooling hair co-wash
it's got tea tree oil and it's my
favorite you ever had a tea tree it kind
of tingles oh that's decadent I use a
tea tree shampoo once a week I kind of
want to drink this smoothing cut hair
co-wash avocado don't taste it no coco
real quick one of the spider characters
we see that I'm certain will be included
in the the breakdowns coming out on our
channel in the next few days uh looked
like he had a paper bag over his head oh
yes
um is that a Gong Show spider or is that
it's a man called is it the bombastic
the bombastic Bag Man uh and he pretends
to be Spider-Man but he wears a bag over
his head and he also Wears Like A
Fantastic Four uniform uh in this
trailer you had more of a Spider-Man
uniform but he usually wears a Fantastic
Four uniform and a bag on his head and
swings around uh doing Spider-Man things
I wanted before we go to mandatory fun
which everyone's waiting for uh match
143 sent in uh what if Jessica is
pregnant with Miguel's baby eventually
becomes spot from the future I like that
idea also said booty beats let it be
numb okay I didn't want to read that
part because I'm trying to have a
serious discussion about Spider-Man that
you seem to have a tough time staying on
track for now uh a serious man like me
will mention
booty B uh
no I think that Miguel himself might be
spot and maybe in one of his experiments
he accidentally turned himself into spot
miles figures that out is going to
reveal Miguel is actually spot and never
see him in the same place at the same
time do you I do have we do have two
different voice actors but that could
just be when he spotties like a
different personality yeah because Jason
schwartzman's doing the spot yeah yeah I
mean I get that but of course so I guess
that would maybe support match 143s I
like that idea slightly better so I like
that also fragirl asked will miles's mom
die in this movie oh I have a I have a
bone chilling Theory oh chill my bones
that clip that we saw is her ghost oh no
because if we're concerned that he won't
take care of himself and he doesn't like
because she doesn't have she can't take
care of him anymore now in the video
game that is not Spider-Man Miles
Morales it is just the regular
Spider-Man for the PlayStation his dad
dies in that game and that's how you
introduced miles morales's character
Peter kind of takes him under his wing
and like you know or his web and uh and
uh his web Wings his web Wings yeah and
he and kind of like Comforts him and
tries to do nice things for him so I'm a
little worried that that may be a a kind
of a uh Ben solo seeing Han Solo on the
moons of Andor uh moment where it's just
you know he's just kind of imagining it
or you know feeling her ghostly
shambling Corp Spirit uh that is bone
chilling all right anyway it's time for
mandatory fun oh
on Spidey day yeah
yeah the segment so Carefree that we
wash our hair constantly playing the
graphic again hit that grab it hit that
graphic come on hit the ground the
segment's so mandatory that it's
sponsored by geology hit it again oh
now Tommy
all right please it cost us one thousand
dollars every time we play that graphic
you're right you're around animation I'm
sorry I can't play the graphic again so
instead place
I think that graphic is perfect the way
it is okay goodbye Occam's razor hello
zezvous ax
in one Fell Swoop Warner Brothers
Discovery CEO David zazlop removed
Westworld canceled Minx and the Nevers
mid production heartless and removed all
of them from the streamer they're gone
HBO Max you can't watch those shows they
were never there they're not a has been
there it never was Mighty Ducks call
1991 movie anyone born then I wasn't
um Brandon was born 10 years after yeah
I was born in 2002. fellas
incorrectly spelled
by me I gotta ask
if you can only say one property okay on
HBO Max starting now okay things that
are gone are gone okay uh you go you
everybody gets a one you can't take them
out What's it gonna be and why and I'm
gonna say Sopranos and Game of Thrones
are excluded and I'm also gonna throw in
White Lotus because I feel like although
White Lotus is in that new category of
HBO Max Originals
I feel like it's safe yeah and for
reasons we talked about off camera
season two is literally a production
right now they're still shooting that
[ __ ] I just think
award recognition White Lotus was so
heavily nominated we had talked about it
off camera it's not an incredibly
expensive show to make it's the
locations where although they're exotic
it's one Resort and then a few kind of
on the street exteriors and uh and a gay
hell mansion in Palermo where murderous
uh mafioso's uh got conspired to kill a
beloved character uh no spoilers no
spoilers one also tell me Well knows as
a a a a veteran working actor uh actors
that work multiple seasons on a show get
paid more yeah in subsequent Seasons
yeah the great thing about White Lotus
is they bring in mostly a new cast
everything seems like zasloff's got a
real chip on his shoulder about paying
out residuals royalties and uh you know
all union jobs Fair pay so uh uh down
with aslov he's got to go uh Union
forever uh anyway which ones are you
guys saving and then I'll reveal my
shocking
there's a lot of stuff that's on HBO Max
but we're saying HBO Originals yes so
we're not counting like uh Cartoon
Network shows yeah listed on there
although they although there are plenty
of animated shows that have gotten the
[ __ ] yeah there's the zaz ax and there's
a zaz shaft and let me tell you you
don't want to be a victim of either
I've got to say but I'm gonna go first
so I can steal Zach's in case the best
show of the year a runaway surprise hit
the most interesting original thing on
television the rehearsal make a
rehearsal every year for the next 50
years give Nathan Fielder there's no way
that cut the show costs that much money
even hiring actors to play every
character we've already seen three times
over setting up a house for an insane
woman making a garden where you just
stick vegetables in the dirt that show's
incredible save the rehearsal zazzlav I
don't know if you have a heart inside of
that stone cold chest of yours but if
you do
save the rehearsal speaking of Stone
Cold if I see you in the streets you're
going to get stunned
a kick to the chest
yeah yeah you can't you're Deborah and
this is Stone Cold Steve Austin
all right um I Well here here's what I'm
gonna say and there's a lot of great
options because HBO's put out a lot of
great shows right like uh Deadwood all
right six feet under Armor's head
um uh and a lot of those are worth and
just a little bit of background so the
removing shows like you can't even not
only they're not gonna make new seasons
you can't watch the old Seasons now
because just having things available as
Library content on a streaming service
they still have to pay out residuals
they're even more diabolical scheme is
they're licensing those shows on other
streamers where those streamers then
become responsible for paying residuals
yeah so like if you stream you know that
you can there's like on-demand residuals
there's all sorts of crazy roku's about
to break out the checkbook yes let's say
and let's hope a lot of these great
shows land on on who or Netflix or
wherever but what I'm going to save and
now this isn't that controversial
because a lot of people talk about this
as the greatest television show ever
made uh I have binged it twice in my
life and you know it might be about time
for a third binge start to finish the
wire
okay if you have not seen the wire and
it wasn't very popular while it was
airing but I think people have
discovered it it's the perfect binge
show yeah it is right um we're like
highly addictive much like the products
each each oh got that pandemic uh each
season of the show is like a novel and
you kind of just plow through it they
will not touch this this is like one of
the great crowning achievements the last
25 years of Television I'm pretty sure
they will leave it up there yeah each
eat your wired dinner and then have a
little we own this city for dessert oh
we own this city yeah Baltimore
uh Tommy get some crabs in a paper bag
uh so anyways you're saving mayor of
these times I'm going to do something
it's gonna shock everyone but first I
want to thank the crazy lizard for their
Super Chat they said they've been
watching since 2018. and they want to
say thanks for making such awesome
content they always liked Marvel but
much more since then hey thank you crazy
crazy lizard as the person who probably
taught you the most I want to say you're
welcome it is my pleasure and now I will
announce the final Safe program on HBO
original ladies and gentlemen
you can count on season three
of fuckboy Island
they ain't messing with my f boy Island
now you called us
well it's 350. get one you get one they
ain't gonna demonetize it at 350. listen
to me F boy Island yeah doesn't have the
prestige and dignity of The Wire yeah it
doesn't have what was yours it doesn't
have the groundbreaking yeah
horror comedy whatever I mean my mom and
I watched binge the rehearsal together
uh well I would love to be in the room
while your mother watches the rehearsal
she loves it oh really my mom loves
comedy I'm telling you right now my mom
was in college when the original
Saturday Night Live came out she is a
comedy connoisseur and she although she
has gotten uh you know older in age but
not older she's not of old age she's
still a young 58 uh plus a few it's just
about your mother's age no she's not 58
she delicious uh no but I'm saying she
she will recommend great comments she
still watches every episode of SNL I
know I'm a mama's boy but I'm just
saying my mom knows funny she loves
Nathan feel that I showed her Nathan for
you so we went we ripped through the
rehearsal we were very disturbed by it
also laughed our butts off and uh you
know he's just a big weirdo that I love
but FYI Island let me just defend this
approach for a second there ain't
nothing you can put on in the background
and be sure you're not going to pay
attention to it while you get work done
than the F boy Island it is the
quintessential and let's put that on and
I'll just work through it so you turn up
you see some hot rods every now and then
back down to the computer I haven't
retained one second of information from
F boy Island and I've seen every episode
I've never watched it is it a real show
or is it like a fake no it's a real it's
a real reality can you give us the two
sentence uh yeah so basically there are
women on the island who are looking for
a good person
they are not looking for that okay there
are men on who come to the island and
they self-identify either as a good guy
or an F boy okay and the F boys jobs are
to convince the girls that they're good
guys and if they do they get money and
the good guys jobs are to get convince
the girls that they're good guys and if
they do they date and if the f boys are
eliminated they go to like a weird F boy
prison on the island where they compete
in challenges again and sometimes can
get out again it seems like I pretended
I'm also just guessing that this is the
point of the show because once again I
have watched every episode without
retaining a second of it but God I love
it if you're looking for beaches babes
Bros Bots bras boobs butts
ABS uh bouncing beach balls beach
volleyball and Nikki Glazer f-boy
okay F boy island is for you zazlov you
touch my f boy Island I make your house
a crater
this is why I want to thank drones I
want to thank Rocky Martin drones for
sponsoring tonight's race uh you know uh
oh I was about to give away our location
um hey the poll in the chat the wire
running away with it hey um that boy
island did a close one no not close my
faith in humanity is restored you guys
have really good taste I knew our
audience had really good taste I knew
yeah they could taste banana peels they
can taste like the inside of greasy fast
food bags okay sometimes they taste the
paint day off again uh the reaction
video the formal reaction starring Eric
MTN Jessica's up on the channel right
now in each of those three hosts is
gonna have their own breakdown analyzing
different elements of that trailer oh
there oh look at that graph that
producer John helped put together that
graphic which is great hey mandatory fun
peeked in at the top hey but
um yeah so we're really excited to watch
all of those breakdowns that's a
strategy is that the vulture yes wow I
know he's blinking you miss him but he
was in that trailer
um but uh we're really excited for all
three of those videos and that's
something we're going to be trying more
and more on the channel as we kind of
like not only do breakdowns but do
breakdowns from different angles and
different hosts Specialties and stuff
like that we think it's gonna greatly
expand the kind of things we can cover
and how we cover them so we're really
excited we appreciate you guys for
joining us today we thank you we hope
you have a wonderful rest of your
Tuesday afternoon or evening whatever
time it is where you are
um what else we got coming up this week
uh uh I gotta go back in to serve the
rest of my jail sentence on Thursday and
Friday so I'm tomorrow's my last day we
gotta we got another breakdown uh for
the Mario clip that aired during the
video games award uh Awards Anna was
breaking her fingers finding all the
little details in there typing them out
there's tons of really cool things in
that clip if you haven't seen it it
actually makes me very excited for this
Mario movie but Brandon and I answered
some deadly we got a big question come
out on Friday about kill counts in phase
four of the MCU you can see uh me and
Eric got uh got all our Wookie freaks a
little Christmas present by uh bringing
the Wikileaks fan back together and
breaking down the Jedi Survivor trailer
sorry I cut you off oh no Eric's got a
primer for Avatar Avatar it's out on the
channel right now yeah yeah if you
haven't seen the first avatar in a while
and don't want to watch it again uh in
preparation for Avatar if you love it
and you can't get enough Avatar in your
life we will probably be talking Avatar
tomorrow we won't have seen it but
there's a lot of news coming out they
had their Premiere last and guess what
they still braid bang and fam don't
worry
all right thank you guys so much raid
banging uh we appreciate you uh keep it
Gucci to muchi as always goodbye
[Music]